la discussion à l'Assemblée nationale
nous a permis d'introduire deux mesures
très importantes sur lesquelles je
souhaitais revenir le gel des points de
sortie des allègements généraux et la
réforme de l'assiette des cotisations et
contributions des travailleurs
indépendants nous allons d'ailleurs nous
attacher à déposer un amendement portant
actualisation des annexes financières du
PLFSS pour que vous ayez la juste vue de
l'impact financier de ces mesures
au-delà de mon intervention de cet
après-midi pour sécuriser la réduction
de notre déficit public dès 2024 nous
avons introduit dans le PLFSS à
l'occasion des débats à l'Assemblée une
mesure de gel des barêes des allègements
généraux nous stabiliserons les barêes à
leur niveau de 2023 s'agissant des
bornes de 2,5 SMIC et 3,5 SMIC ce qui
évitera une Perre de recettes de l'ordre
de 600 million d'euros pour la sécurité
sociale comme vous le savez nous sommes
très prudents sur l'évolution de ces
exonérations en effet il s'agit d'un
déterminant essentiel du coût du travail
que nous avons cherché à abaisser tant
que possible dans une logique à la fois
de compétitivité et d'amélioration du
revenu net des salariés aujourd'hui
cependant comp tenu de la très forte
dynamique du SMIC en lien avec
l'inflation le montant des allaigements
a a augmenté de manière considérable il
devrait coûter 80 milliards d'euros en
2024 la structure de ces allègements
s'est également déformée au profit des
salaires moyens ou élevés dans la
distribution alors même que leur
efficacité est plus élevé pour les
salaires les moins élevés ainsi le
dispositif de gel permettra d'une part
de modérer la dynamique d'exonération et
d'autre part de préserver le montant
global des réductions accordées aux
employeurs ainsi que la répartition
entre les secteur économique concernés
ce qui donne toute la visibilité la
prévisibilité nécessaire aux entreprises
la deuxième mesure que nous avons
introduite et la réforme de l'assiette
des cotisations et contribution des
travailleurs indépendants grande réforme
de simplification administrative il
s'agit surtout d'une réforme créatrice
de droits sociaux nouveaux l'ambition
est d'améliorer les droits à la retraite
des travailleurs indépendants du fait de
la reconfiguration des contributions et
cotisations leur CSG diminuera et leur
assiette de cotisation augmentera c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs cette réforme a
recueilli le plein soutien de l'UDP de
la CPME étroitement concerté le projet
qui vous est soumis est le fruit
d'échang nombreux et correspond à des
modifications substantielles de la
proposition initiale du gouvernement ce
gain sera fonction de la majoration des
cotisations de retraite complémentair à
laquelle procéderont les différents
régimes professionnels et dur des droits
acquis au sein de ces régimes le cadrage
de la réforme impose une neutralité
financière globale elle illustre notre
capacité à conduire des réformes
complexes qui permettent à la fois
l'acquisition de droits nouveaux et la
préservation de not trajectoire
financière elle démontre qu'il est
possible d'avancer d'améliorer la vie de
nos concitoyens sans dégrader les
déficits